it's absolutely deafening inside this
cockpit
you have an engine that is screaming
loud in front of you the cockpits 140
degrees inside everything is shaking
vibrating in its own different way why
would you want to do something like this
bottom line is every pilot wants to go
fast
Steve heaven is trying to set the
fastest speed ever accomplished with a
propeller driven piston engine aircraft
to break this record you have to be
perfect this is the pinnacle of aviation
Steve's dad wrote the record of 499
miles an hour there's only a few people
that have ever stood on top of this
mountain
the Wright brothers Jimmy Doolittle Glen
Curtiss Howard Hughes just these icons
of aviation and Steve believes he is the
man to do it
5:35 is the magic number if we go 535
miles an hour that's a new world record
[Music]
my dad was definitely a hero of mine he
also erased he set world speed records
and won several races with an airplane
called the Red Baron and he's alive to
tell the tale about it at the scene of
the crash medics have recovered Steve
Hinton from the shattered cockpit of the
Baron this is serious business and I've
been severely hurt I broke my back and
broke my legs when I crashed the Red
Baron for instance but I I was young and
I healed well and now this medevac
helicopter is the key to survival for
Steven you know it's funny being part of
an aviation family when Steve senior
crashed the Red Baron I it never even
occurred to me to say don't fly you
can't separate someone from their soul
fifteen years ago was the first time I
really got bit by this air racing bug
[Music]
I dug through my parents attic and found
a bunch of old photographs of my dad
from his racing days and found his
trophy which he got for setting the
world speed record he held that record
for 10 years until while Shelton broke
that same record at 528 miles an hour it
is still considered one of the hardest
records to break
the allure just kind of pulled me in is
like this gravitational force but having
an opportunity to break a speed record I
thought was a beyond a longshot
[Music]
our family operates a warbird museum
based in chino california that is
dedicated to preserving maintaining
flying these aircraft my sister and I
had a crib in my mother's office here
while she was doing the books and some
of my earliest memories are waddling out
into the hangar and seeing my dad
working on the aircraft
[Music]
you know he was probably a baby sitting
out next to the toolbox when his dad was
taking an engine apart before he could
talk he probably was already getting it
though you know warbirds of a speaker
special in her family we are really
intrigued with the mechanical and of
them the history they were built for war
they're built for combat they're built
for killing but they were the Apollo
spaceships in their day there is a
mystique that surrounds these aircraft
there was no computers that built them
they're all hand-built
calculated with slide rules puzzles and
paper you know to be able to understand
how the entire aircraft works it's just
a really important part of being a pilot
of a world war 2 aircraft steve-o has
grown up with that expectation that
you'll really know your airplane when
you work on it and once he started
racing you started winning
I was able to win my first year out at
the age of 22 which bested my dad's
record of being the youngest to win in
Aires and then I was lucky enough to win
seven of eight races over the last eight
years and that was a big deal he won his
first four big races he boo boo boom won
and beat everybody handily without any
trouble it was just this total
cinderella story how many men have tried
to win the unlimited gold and have never
even won a heat race there's guys that
have done this for 40 years and only won
seven times that felt like the last way
to leave your impression on a sport is
to go after the speed record because
once this breed of airplane is extinct
it won't be capable of being broken
again
for this record attempt we've come to a
private ranch which our sponsor Joe
Clarke owns which is an ideal location
for the record he's got his own run away
on it and he's given us the opportunity
to try and make history there's some
better places to do this at but the
runway isn't long and the terrain is
horrible
I mean there are literally an infinite
amount of areas here that you could
safely land this airplane on its belly
and not get hurt the engine blows he's
got to get it on the ground we got a lot
of runway here and we have overruns at
both ends
it's gonna take a lot of skill and
concentration and machinery I mean this
machine is going to be running at 3,600
horsepower and there's only maybe two or
three other airplanes in old world that
can do this at this level
the aircraft that we're using to break
this record is what's called a North
American p-51 Mustang and we've named it
voodoo
p51 changed the war the aerodynamics of
the airplane were such that it was far
superior to many other aircraft around
it
you might say its own warbird and you
know there's new airplanes that can do
this and that's just not true
that's as good as going to get
[Music]
it's a small airframe which means it's
shaped like a bullet it's real quick
and it really has lent itself into being
a nice racing platform thank you my dad
and I aren't emotionally close people
it's a very business type of
relationship we've talked about
mechanical aspects and how things work
but as far as how would you do this how
would you do that I haven't gotten much
advice from him at all he thought it
would be more beneficial for me to
experience my own thought process they
don't have to say I love you everyday
the fact that they work together on
things is the bond and it's kind of the
glue that holds us together
I know you know this pulsating light the
time of day makes big difference and you
know the sleigh can read over the clouds
to the ground looks different every time
so that's why the more flying better
we're about two o'clock right now
missile you know we're gonna be doing it
between two three four five some on
there so he's assuming a lot of
responsibility which is a lot of load I
kept an eye on him quite a bit but you
know he's handling it well but I think
it's adding to the stress level they
doesn't need
[Music]
prior to flying the airplane I'm a
hundred and ten percent mechanic the big
key to us breaking this record will be
the aerodynamics of the airplane the
design is so solid that we can push the
limits a little bit more than what it
was designed for
[Music]
every aspect of this air point is so far
beyond the envelope it was originally
intended to do because of that the
engine is commonly breaking this engine
is going to be completely stressed it's
going to be flying at power longer than
it has to during the near race there's a
tremendous amount of maintenance that
goes on with it that includes tests
flying at full power
[Music]
it's probably the most dangerous part of
this record is the edge
what you're trying to do is get it to go
to the absolute maximum without breaking
there's this fuse once we start opening
up the throttle on this engine that fuse
gets lit how long the fuses no one knows
how long the fuses
[Music]
it's a lot of passion you have
mechanical failures you have lots of
late nights you got to always try and
see that light at the end of the tunnel
even though you may not see it you have
to have faith that it's there
[Music]
[Applause]
should be starting up here in the next
half an hour obviously the first
priority is that this is a safe flight
we're obviously going for a speed record
but the priority is to be on the ground
safely so if the airplane does have some
sort of an emergency or Mayday we ask
that everybody just stay away from the
runway
I'm not going to swerve to miss you so
[Applause]
pilots have been looking at the old
record for many many years waiting for
someone to come and break it to do it
he must fly over this course four times
two times in each direction to come up
with a final average speed he must
exceed the current record by 1%
my job today is be the chase plane if I
see something doesn't look right I'll be
able to watch him and help him so I'll
be running to shoulder with him we're
lucky we'll get one crack at this record
if we're not successful we are really
rolling the dice to try and set this
thing again
these engines are like people they talk
to you and in this particular case it's
got to last probably 10-15 minutes once
we start opening up the throttle on this
engine it could go within the first 45
seconds
I thought I heard off power but I'm not
sure I don't know what that means
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're just setting up for making that
attempt on the speed record and climbed
out ducked altitude started coming up on
power things go nice got the horse in
sight grew up on full power for about 10
or 15 seconds and got a little Steve's
like a little up and then up boom and it
blew a bunch of [ __ ] out of the exhaust
stacks so we eat the cord of made aether
and cruise on in and landed it's still
making power I saw the oil pressure so
we don't know what the issue is at the
moment there is cooling all over the
right side of the airplane so we will go
back to work and see if we figure out
what's happening and how to get her back
in the sky yeah
[Music]
who's gonna have to look it over and
determine what happened is it could be
major or it could be some simple we
don't know at this point but the
airplanes here Steve's here so if it
just needs a apart or something we'll
find a way you really have to be ready
for those punches to get thrown at you
in this industry because it is 75 year
old equipment but I'm so proud of these
guys
normal people wouldn't do the stuff that
we're doing they would have quit a long
time ago
[Music]
it's not natural to fly I don't care who
you are
you have to get experience understanding
limitations understanding consequences
unfortunately we've had friends or with
us anymore and Steve has gone through
that
as a mother you can't go through these
kinds of things unaffected
you vibrate with every core of your
being during these experiences
I don't want to watch him do this again
and I know I know that's what they do
they blow the engine they change it and
they go again and and it's just not
gonna be very easy to watch alright if
you like it I like it
the pilot has to fly it perfect the
airframe has to work perfect the engine
needs to run perfectly everything has to
come together for it to be perfect we're
not doing this record for somebody else
we're not doing this for another group
of people we're not trying to prove that
we're faster than anybody we're doing
this for ourselves okay I'm gonna start
coming
[Music]
okay clock is rolling
[Music]
it's absolutely deafening inside this
cockpit you have an engine that is
screaming aloud in front of you there's
18 different gauges in the cockpit
they're trying to keep track of
[Music]
in the midst of all this chaos you talk
to the engine
talk to the airplane it's you and the
piece of equipment you and the machine
okay I got eighty on an uncannily man
there it's been an all-consuming project
for the last four to five years
all this work throughout the year all of
these moments of dreaming telemetry ISM
it essentially comes down to 30 seconds
yep yeah ever get under background get
the first thing your mind is come on
you can hold together there's only a
little bit left
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no in the white hand is successful we're
back on the ground between the third and
fourth pass the oil pressure started
falling off so be interesting to see how
the speeds reflect the four passes will
wait for about an hour until Brian Utley
from the NAA does his calculations and
make sure I didn't break in the altitude
restrictions and then we'll get an
average of the four laps and see what we
got
everybody together
let me walk you through the numbers but
I think it's important to know the
numbers the old record five twenty eight
point three three you said old record so
that means there's a new graphic we must
exceed a current record by one percent
so with the first lap the first to pass
Steve average five hundred and fifty
four point six nine miles an hour
fantastically fantastic on the second
pass he averaged five hundred and twenty
seven point three four for an average
over the two passes of five hundred and
forty-one on the third pass he averaged
five hundred and twenty eight point four
eight miles an hour for a three pass
average of five hundred and thirty six
point eight four on the fourth pass
unfortunately he only averaged five
hundred and fifteen point six miles an
hour which dropped his overall average
down to 531 and I'm sorry I can't give
you better news but through the third
lap they was there and so but but
congratulations for a great
[Applause]
it's real when he you know told us to
speed in this is the average is like huh
that's it you know in the end no
fairytale ending no fireworks no
celebration is just kind of this huh
this engine ran real well but it
unfortunately missed the beat by about
30 seconds we do our best to figure all
the variables but that's racing before
the fourth pass the oil pressure began
fluctuating and these engines when they
start losing oil pressure something is
gonna explode and that's faced with this
decision of do I go out do I come back
so I just quickly turn the airplane
around but I can feel that it bled a lot
of speed off I know the limitations is
the airplane I know what I can get away
with I know what I can't get away with
and this was a decision that was right
on the edge of that
[Music]
it's a bit hard going to sleep at night
because it'll keep me up you know you
always go through the what-ifs so I tend
to try not to think about it and
hopefully there will be a next chapter
at some point
you know it's like just missing Everest
to set the record you have to beat the
previous record by 1% it doesn't sound
like a lot but when you're pushing the
speeds that these guys are pushing it's
very difficult to do
[Music]
you know you set a goal and it went out
and executed it just like they had
planned and with any luck you know Steve
might get another chance - do we know
where to improve the airplane we know
where to improve the engine and that
gives us hope that if we do get a chance
to do this again we'll be able to break
that five greater than 35 mile an hour
number as a matter of fact now we have
to go 536 miles an hour cuz we have to
break our old record by 1% so here we go
[Music]